[Music]
right in this process we can smartly
from already too noisy GPS data you know
exactly where then we can also do some
predictions what are the most likely
it's funny all right this way
based on your previous revoluta we might
be ready to take automatically a momenta
if you have several of those maybe use a
different car computer hours compared to
a business trip d'etre or meteorites we
can know machine learning models to
optimize what driver gets a special or
predicting the ETA of your aircraft is
groceries or picking up the right
matching hazards the finished area so
every part of experience as machine
learning arrogant the abundance of
machine learning researcher is what he
not just the classic lived experience
aside from that we have a ton of people
working on autonomous driver using deep
learning extensively for computer vision
and etiquette so my team's job is to
build a machine that makes it easy to
[Music]
develop new models prototype many
different approaches to machine learning
model once you have a few models that
you have selected you want to make it
easy for you to try out different
training algorithms you might want to be
learning rate on your model and try
order for 30 days I have different
optimizers
I can't be make it easy
[Music]
once you have a marble that performs the
best we also make it easy for you to
shift that into production there are
different paths to reduction or a marble
that runs during the every quest or
serving arrive it needs to be served as
a dexterous other models may do some
kind of a flying condition on a daily
basis or a weekly basis for example we
bring down the right population to do
send out an incentive there is a third
kind of difference which might be a
machine learning automatic of the edge
for example an autonomous car so how do
we make it easy across all these
different active deployments or recent
science research scientist and a lot of
time doing non-article a dataset ready
they be put through here slice and dice
able to generate correctly then if your
training really compute-intensive models
like the floating models you need to be
able to provision in the right hardware
for your model you might never run many
different iterations of those powers you
go to lobby and and part of the job is
to make all of that system so I'm going
to get into some of those requirements
to start over we wanted to build a
system that's framework agnostic the
current density of so rapidly changing
there are some unique reading words like
tensorflow by current that have come up
in the last few years and then there is
the whole ecosystem or boosted trees any
new libraries that come up so we want to
or any arbitrary paperwork and not be
tied to implementation support for duty
workers almost all of the deep learning
model car extremely computer intensive
several orders of magnitude is more than
traditional machine learning approaches
and we want to serve those internal
customers to them who are training in
very large scale models that feel
imagery or video data and model trading
that can offer taste how can you make
your job easier and support single GPU
much in GPU or distributor 20 rows we
wanted to the system big flower master
and the main reason for that is along
with the software ecosystem the hardware
ecosystem or which meaning is also
rapidly evolving I study but I totally
had shows there's almost 10x improvement
year-over-year in ml compute performance
which is extremely fast and there are
custom accelerators
ASIC based model trading systems that
are being developed in media has the
voltage GPU which is the current
state-of-the-art GPU for not operating
however Google's working on few chips
that there are and we want have to be
able to leverage any of this hardware
because we cannot anticipate exactly how
this ecosystem is going to perform so we
wanted to be flabbergasted now with a
lot of desire responsibilities right
however we have many levels of users we
have researchers who come from academic
background and don't really wanna deal
with a large structure problems they
don't want to be certain
two logical jobs however for some
advanced use cases such as is to be
training our if you want to be custom
ops for your internal market we also
have very advanced Illumina software
engineer users who want to get the
maximum flexibility around defining
their products so in order to support
report such use cases so we decided to
use container docker containers has a
rare special for most of our jobs this
is all of our problems dependency
management it is easy to be revered
master as long as you can hand it your
code into our document you can run it on
our system now with containers we need
to decide a good execution into those
containers and the kubernetes ecosystem
has really long known over the last few
years
cooper- provides a very rich set of KPIs
or launching very complex workflows you
can scale out very easy any of the
flower providers it provides a cloud
agnostic api first to launch jobs which
in then translate ridiculous to google
power to any custom deployments it
handle is a lot of different
infrastructure challenges it's one of
the challenges were using however is it
is very complex there's no ability right
so i'll show how we create the right
abstractions to have our users large of
interest we decided to go the route of
riding easy that is only UI based so we
have our base system
[Music]
so this is the so this is in the
he is able to provide their own software
environments in the form of docker
images so if you hear about a certain
set of requirements which are different
for most users
and you want to pin your future to
scikit-learn or we use our super
internet scroll you can do that employ
it as a tester next you pick the
hardware resources see part of this Java
so we provide some pre-configured
hardware requirements you can choose
many different configurations of CPU
memory and GPU that will be like real
job for your noticed having some ethics
in the biometric choices makes it easy
for users to quickly go through this
flow however you can use the command
line codes to arbitrarily which
translates to kubernetes resources
behind here we are so you click Next and
now you have
in the background this is these are some
of the links that are available to you
you have your face and you have the
control for visualizing in the
background we're creating two political
objects primarily won't be hard
ours are things so here we are launching
the heart a given set of Python
requirements along with the right
resources requests that the user
submitted it was an image but using it
[Music]
along with other part we attached
certain particles a woman can represent
either temporarily dissipates the use of
marijuana for deliveries of datasets or
such as checkpoints community
checkpoints for your models we can also
we've also mount NFS into these parts so
we have either velocity of S which we
mounted as a persistent water
the primary use gives there is a usual
intercept artery vertical start
developing a new model say if there are
no rules on the DFS and once you're done
make intermediate environments come back
again next day and start where you left
off so it's it makes good use of the
resources by letting you checkpoint all
your work and come back to it at a later
point we also provide half days
integration so let's say you've done
[Music]
so lonely a new job can become a
bottleneck because I take a long time so
what we do is that's one of our
approaches or pre-caching most commonly
used images today this helps us
eliminate half of all time also I was
feeling so based on the skill of the
number of instances however itself
starting a new instance can take a while
as well we use pattern which is a
or generally the first or many other
activities this helps us create the
image prevail as needed to launch on it
occurs so we combine there's other thing
we need to do with notebooks you want
it's really fast
however once you can you know and take
up to six seven minutes downloading the
image if it's not in ten minutes so we
saw both of those power-ups between a1 -
extra doors available for both CPU and
GPU types and so forth it is kowax quick
priority classes which we can use to
create lower priority jobs that can be
created with this allows us to specify X
propensity or jobs that are just there
just waiting to be preempted by ropes
this allows us to make the notebook
experience extremely fast we're able to
provide the system note for how much
times within 10 seconds or these 50
being images of kubernetes this makes it
so however you provided good
interpretation just from the UI
credentials to get our final register
these credentials get translated to
cooperate in secret objects the
kubernetes secret objects is if it's
accessible in this table we do store
arbitrary on the back in datastore or
exceed these are available at rest and
they can be monitored so once you set up
your guitar cover once you set up your
credentials once you set up your risk of
potentials then we become automatically
available on your container during any
book or creation so you can access
external data source or video doing it
yourself and the same way or publishing
you Peter so interrupt organ is a
potential access to can also be all
right so let's talk about training and
deployment once you go up a little
bottle and you just want to try out
different optimizers
let's say for learning model it's very
common to try out different number it is
both a lot of exploration and we wanna
make the exploration we asked and all of
these jobs can launch hundreds of jobs
with different learning create or
different optimizers